and I tried and now ladies and gentlemen
fasten your seat belts you know
man your battle station in the ice and
of course the great Olli this game is
for saying I'm so pretty I'm ready to
rumble rumble young man Rumble boo
beanie Brown would join in they go with
float like a butterfly sting like a baby
so I started to say let's get ready to
rumble [ __ ] we have him bring it in
please welcome flee that means to off
you do that we can we can do something
of course can we get uh let's get ready
to hotbox and now for the thousands in
attendance and the millions around the
world who wish they could be here ladies
and gentlemen let's get ready for hot
boxes
that was awesome
well there it is everybody welcome to
another episode of hot box and I'm Evan
Britton and I'm Mike Tyson I'm Mike
we've got the voice in here nothing bad
about it good to be here 35 years wow
that's amazing what was that like the
beginning back to 1985 jeez I started in
82 I was a disaster
the first 85 proto by 85 oh yeah I was
introducing you by 85 man well Mike was
Mike was doing for rounders and six
rounders and he and you were like
fighting every six weeks 15 fights in
one year yeah that's you know I'm people
people today there's like you're amazed
by that but you know you're a student of
the game and you go back and you look at
Sugar Ray Robinson who I still think is
the greatest pound-for-pound fighter in
the history of the game but when he
fought Jake LaMotta he was 40 you know
yeah he had already fought LaMotta once
and beaten him this is now in their
second fight yes I remember listen to
this guy ray all over the world listen
to it Ray was a welterweight and Jake
was a middleweight 14 pounds didn't make
any difference they fought because they
were just the hottest fighters in New
York at the time they fight a second
time and LaMotta wins the fight his
first loss he's 40 you know he's still a
welder way they fight again 21 days
later yes but wait it gets better
ray fights a 10-round her in between him
agree before you frightful amazed him by
then he wins and then over over his next
80 fights Sugar Ray Robinson goes
undefeated over his next 80 fights until
he fights for the light heavyweight
championship but in the rain he lost in
his 40th fight and then went undefeated
for like 80 fights what do you know laws
one day went undefeated for 80 it's
unbeliev it was the guy that he fought
for the light heavyweight title
Joey Joey max I knew mr. Mac from real
well before he died a no real great
story there too because III tell it to
the way in those days in New York you
had to weigh in the morning of the fight
yes now you know today any light
heavyweight or any middleweight that's
going to fight its super middleweight or
light heavyweight comes in at the limit
they put it on the way cuz they're all
like you know they're all emaciated when
they weigh themselves in day before yeah
so try to imagine this race fighting for
the light heavyweight title he's the
middleweight champ yeah he weighs in at
159 pounds he's fighting for the light
heavyweight title he could no he walks
around at 159 every day he weighs in at
115 Joey Maxim ways
what 173 whatever cuz that's in those
days the guys were really that's what
they weight the fight gets postponed at
Yankee Stadium because of thunderstorms
electrical storms so it's a Saturday
night they sorry scheduled for Monday
night Yankee Stadium Monday and they
have to weigh in again on morning and if
that happened today those guys would be
20 pounds overweight yeah absolutely do
that today huh and the only reason Ray
lost is because in those days the
fighter didn't swallow his water between
rounds yep yes and spit it out yeah they
didn't they weren't really up on
hydration yeah they carried the referee
out of the ring after the 10th 11th
round Ruby goldstein right did you carry
the referee passed out alternate referee
comes in to him Ray Ray lost 10 to 15
pounds yes and and passed out at the end
of the 14th and he was ahead but listen
Wow
but this is interesting right yeah the
fact that he lost with the best
performance of his life that was his
best performance by far it's brilliant
yeah and collapse from me wow that's
amazing you know thank God for you too
because we can tell these stories and
now people can go and look at like a
definite I used to talk to Joey Maxim
all the time cause he was a pit pit bull
in the hotel and Vegas and the boxing
here
and I would go and talk to him every
[ __ ] day every night there was a
nighttime but it's gonna nighttime and I
would talk to him would you talk about
fighting yeah I talked to him about the
Robinson fight and I said how did you
see that I didn't worry about foot Adam
will he's a little bitty guy wasn't
worrying about it my foot Adam oh he's
nothing he can't hurt me I foot add my
foot walk car you know me I'm foot
Charles and all these guys this guy
can't hurt me yeah and those days the
heavy weights were 185 90 pounds before
had me for the heavy weight pattern all
these guys I wanted to martyr so bad
they wouldn't give me LaMotta I wanted
him so bad - Marisa morning I wanted to
Malvika that was the money fighting
Amato with the big draw money people
didn't know that back then the mana made
a lot of money is the big draw listen
Detroit the black city need the biggest
draw in Detroit when he when he fights
in Detroit he's the biggest draw LaMotta
yeah Raging Bull you want us title in
Detroit right Pete know who did it be
sir dad or that man yeah hmm the history
of boxing god that's amazing these guys
today what do they fight two fights a
year it's a year when when Ray was 46
years old his final year I think he
fought like 13 or 14 times going going
10 rounds haven't got the record with 35
fights a year can you believe this man
that's crazy animal absolute well you
did 15 yeah there's nothing to 35:30 how
much listen I listen this isn't for me I
have 15 fight the yeah I didn't have
enough time to go to gym and train and
spar Kyle afraid imagine um they must
have had drink fans went back in the
rink I had to walk around and if they
had to make weight they had to walk
around hitting straight yeah you know
they'd get a call on a Tuesday can you
you know can you make it saturday night
I got a 10-round or four year like yeah
they had him and they had to make weight
and despairs she walked around if their
pants were tight they knew not to eat
dinner so had to be if they can't make
the way to fight that the other fails
I'll fight you because you gotta give me
ten
anomalous do you don't give me the you
need the money so you have to give him
the money the phylogenetic I was only
making forty forty five hundred anyways
yeah Wow
that's crazy yeah I mean I guess that's
how would you feel about that Mike
having to be in shape all the time that
wasn't her just camp you were it's all
my life that's what we did with work or
they went fifteen fourteen thirteen and
like cuts who called me and called my
school to say he's a bad was a bad
accident at the house he knew we needed
him right away we have a problem at home
and so they'd send me out of school I
would go to the gym test the box for
father like Frank Bruno somebody a call
to choose Williams
you know up-and-coming fighters and I
would boxing me get experienced boxing
with them I just I just saw Frank a few
weeks ago in London the guy looks like
he has a 30 inch waist he's such a
striking good-looking guy and people
when I do with the introductions at the
London no to the biggest hand is always
for Frank Bruno they love him the
British fans are great yeah I met him I
did a Tony Simpson fight in the 80 came
beautiful guy and he passed away with a
beautiful old-time fighter old-school
bleeder though yeah fight you to the
death he had some greatness and he
dropped a drop dolly dolly tough forgot
about that he has him knockity-knock
some guy dead food he knocked the female
after mountain 91 1971 a left hook but
they woke up this morning Rip Van Winkle
all old now this [ __ ] hey daddy knock
them dead wow great left hook that that
reminds me of what do you guys think
about this this young fighter that just
recently died and coming down Ukrainian
guy two kids just died Dada chef
what I mean I guess they said you know
there's video of him talking to his
trainer with his trainer right but yeah
talking to his trainer and he's saying
you know if you can't protect your head
I'm gonna have to stop them to tell them
to stop the fight how do you get into a
position like that as a fighter where
you're you can't you're not defending
enough to protect yourself
sometimes being a fighting and hey
sometimes you get in a state of um what
is that what is this almost it's almost
a state of bliss you don't need euphoria
yeah you see it going on but you can't
stop it doesn't even hurt but it
stimulated your brain it stopped your
brain for a second hmm sometimes you may
buffer hang you in some letteth going on
then you slowly die well it's you know a
lot of people you know we look at Ollie
and Parkinson's syndrome and everything
and it's not like Ali had a career where
he took beatings or anything hmm
but I used to go to Deer Lake before I
was even in this business and watch him
train and you know put the head gear and
not I used to love to go hold on the
ropes in a corner like this and let guys
like Larry Holmes just you know beat on
his body and like then you know they
were slipping everything but he wasn't
afraid to take shots in training because
they just have that headgear on people
don't realize you take two
thirteen-year-old girls and if they have
a pillow fight every night one of them
could end up punchy yeah only you never
know how many blows you can take just
because it's soft and you're protected
you know not a big fan of having I think
in Nevada 140 powders now have to use 10
ounce gloves you see guys getting beat
up
whereas they'd be better off with eights
and just get whacked out you know and
five weeks later they're they're you
know in good shape why do they have more
ten ounce gloves they assume that
technically it's more of a cushion when
it's
that's just a heavier knocked out with
any size club yeah died eating die with
any size club 18 out of 20 two ounces 10
ounces these kids that play soccer and
they practice headers yeah a hundred
headers a day yeah you know yeah that's
you know some guy kicks the ball at you
and you're and you're doing a header
with it yeah science proved it the
one-drop top top top of water will drive
you insane absolutely kill you
it's imagine punch it yeah that's just a
drop of water would make you punch to
make you brain dead Samantha really
punches and beaten you down with flips
and kicks and knees and elbows water
what do we do it hmm
is there a way to take a punch to the
head other than blonko nobody can kill
you gonna be like this like this yeah
usually it's an accumulation yeah blows
yeah and then one yeah it's just like
you know the worst thing we always hate
to see this win this one was that limits
a couple of death yeah yeah and I almost
like try to just block him out cuz it's
just yeah and one I forget who the kid
was it happened at the Taj Mahal and
then they found that later that the
manager the guy at lost four weeks prior
should have been on a 30 day it's no
training and that and it was anything he
fought in Canada so they slipped it
through and you know they put him in the
ring and he shouldn't have been in the
ring mm-hmm when I was a kid I still
remember as clear as can be
with Benny kid pret and amyl Griffith
and I mean I mean I can see in my mind
and knew that he was done I remember do
Koo Kim like it was yesterday
you wouldn't think if you sort of fight
you wouldn't think Dooku Kim was losing
really he was throwing down well he was
going down
that's so interesting that you could be
taking that damage and not even really
you don't feel it obviously they're on
autopilot someone that so guys getting
back now : it don't punch it yeah
background if don't put some actor on
the floor Tommy Morrison when when
Mercer knocked enough he'll Putney was
place thrown punches well well while
they were the doctor was there why is
that you just program that is it's an
instinct yeah yeah that's crazy
did the consciousness still remember
we're fighting yeah that's really
interesting we did you get knocked into
another dimension mmm-hmm but you still
fighting in this dimension
yeah well Michael how how has it been
watching Mike since he was a kid I'm
gonna come up and seeing you know you've
seen me go through the craziness almost
killing my foot I'm one of my favorite
stories about Mike is when he's fighting
that the 4 is in the sixes and come to
Atlantic City and we had that back then
ESPN was like a fledgling cable yeah
network and the number one show on ESPN
before they had football and everything
was top-ranked boxing on ESPN well he
usually would be like that group of
faith too yeah yeah parfaits great
buffet that's in the buffets that's why
the press was always there you know the
press press they loved that free food
yeah in the buffet so Mike was coming in
as this you know young guy so anyway
he's coming to the ring I don't know
he's like 6 in know 1800 knockouts
whatever he's coming to the ring you
know and Atlantic City is known for a
lot of Vinny boom boxes you know AI
adorned
just going on hey yo Vinnie oh yeah
those two guys are sitting at ringside
it might comes out you know he's been
seen on ESPN in USA and it's before he
started getting those weekend fights you
know on the network TV he's got the
black shoes low-cut you know high you
know yeah low low high tops you know no
socks solid black trunks the towel was
just the whole cutout you know these
guys hey look at this guy
ooh hey where's your socks in there I
don't know who was it was like 92
minutes in boom knockout and I can
remember like you know and these two
guys like Eileen after I announced you
know the winner by the you know knockout
victory and I leaned over and said hey
want to ask him about the Sox now
wearing those Versace shirts
fake for Saji shirts with 100 chain they
were looking good though that was the
eighties well it's true they had you
know the mullets and no but oh my god
that's such a scene how did you get into
this what was your how did you like I
mean dude your voice is iconic they made
a [ __ ] video game ready to rumble
yeah yeah that was my first big big
chick okay anyway that was huge on
PlayStation what was that on it was like
a special player yeah Dreamcast yeah
that's right I had it too and then when
you got to the end you would fight you
and you would like morph into this giant
muscular same fighting I told about it
but I'm not a video game guy I just took
the checks you know way back then you
got a lot of [ __ ] girls in you
the man back there ya know tell ya I was
[ __ ] between after from 1972 to
1997-98 I was single and those were good
days they're a single man was insane how
did you get into it we're talking about
all these fights and everything in
Atlantic City and I'm a big boxing fan a
super fan my oldest son is probably
about 12 or 13 at the time we're
watching the fights on TV it's a split
decision the ring announcer remember
Frank Shane Frank Shane was a ring
announcer his wife Eva Shane was Eva
yeah and her husband's Frank and Frank
used to do ring announcing and a good
announcer is you know he experienced
everything but I didn't realize that it
was sort of like a common thing a lot of
guys would give a score and instead of
giving you the two different scores and
saving the winner for the final score
this guy just announced score one score
two and then you know who won the fight
hmm so I guess those guys are rings
severed hey no one to fight oh that
drama of like you know for the winner by
split decision and no you know yeah you
know you get big man everybody's waiting
they shot up and listen you get that
Cathedral moment you know pop the crowd
so my son goes like I mean he literally
just like throws a TV Guide down he's
like oh man I hate that you know dad you
could do that at the time I was making a
living as a model and I'd been doing
some TV commercials and getting little
speaking parts here and there so I guess
a 12 13 year-old kid thought you know
all the same thing announcer and I put
together a you know a resume that might
have said I had experience which of
course I didn't and but the thing I
pushed back then was I sent him a
headshot I didn't know that
promoters hire the announcers I thought
maybe the hotel-casino did so I
contacted all the directors of
entertainment in Atlantic City and I
included a headshot it was like that
James Bond sort of a look you know and
and I said that the image of the hotel I
put this in writing like what a jerk-off
but I did it you know and and suggested
that the the image of a hotel casino
would have that James Bond look you know
a little and so one of them bit and said
like asked you know the promoter to use
me I was dreadful was on USA fights on
their table I was really the main event
you know I remember some of the names
one of the guys name was his nickname
was the Hebrew hitter Oh herb the Hebrew
hit her something Brad Jacobs knows
exactly what his name is to this day I
can't remember but there was some I
don't remember any of them becoming
stars but it was six months before I got
another chance Wow you know it I
videotaped it I looked at it and I said
and I still to this day I will like
occasionally look at a show and try to
improve I'm just very conscious of
always trying to be a little bit better
what was it that what was that first
that first fight what was it about it
that you were like I could do way better
than that were you just not yet and your
voice yet yet in founders yeah yeah I've
I've always tried to improve technique
you know on microphone and and that sort
of thing but yeah timing and be a little
more familiar with the scorecards and
and you know that sort of thing I I was
for years I used to do all the fights
and then today I just do the main event
but and I would get there early I would
go to each dressing room make sure I had
the right color the trunks and their
records and I know what I was always
amazed that like sometimes you go into a
dressing room I'd say you know the
undercard guys I'd say is this right 20
wins and 5 losses and they fight it
would go I don't know look at his
manager as coach he'd see ya there he
would know his own record
is crazy we you know we used to do
fights in Merrillville Indiana French
Lick Indiana the crazy excites for
top-ranked yeah and you had you know a
lot of small-town guys I don't know if
they were the best fighters in the world
but they could put on a pretty good show
yeah yeah they were fighting for their
life probably oh yeah
hey yes they were what was the first
fight where he came up with let's get
ready to rumble
yeah happen you know here's the thing
excuse me one second let me call my
lawyer
oh yeah anyway you know we started we
were in the era now in the 80s of the
main event it's music they have speakers
and it's exciting fighters come to the
ring you know and the ring walk a
spotlight and everything so you have
this energy
you know people come especially we would
have fights and resorts in a ballroom
and the theaters those elegant things
when we came I would say wow look at the
lights in the theaters didn't have all
these banquettes the VIPs those many
guys again Hey look at a guy ring and it
so taking pictures we had ring
announcers somewhere along the line some
ring announcers started they introduced
all their buddies on the Commission you
know a New Jersey State Athletic
Commission state I thought a control
board boxing commissioner Robert Lee and
then they would introduce the the
chairman the commissioners the board
members the corniche the judges of
course and all the doctors and if it was
a title fight good job the president of
the WBC a unified fight president WBA to
their supervisors that you killed the
crowd yeah I mean you actually you know
the crowd hears all this the music the
lights that come out it's exciting
fighters are ready Mike is it
like disco and you've taken away you've
taken away all that energy right right
so one of the greatest expressions that
gets a crowd energized is gentlemen
start your engines man and I did that at
the Indy 500 and the place goes nuts
okay I wanted I wanted something that
for the stars of the show when I grew up
as a kid I used to love to watch the
baseball all-star game and they would
plate an ounce each player and they'd
line up on third base and first base and
I just thought that was so exciting to
see the stars of the show and the place
would go nuts you know so to me I wanted
that the audience to be pumped up for
the for the guys that just came out and
are gonna go out there and do the thing
and be training for six weeks the
fighters they're the stars yeah and so I
I wanted to come up with a hook that
would let the audience know okay I
introduced all this [ __ ] now I want
you to get back in line in and give
these guys a hand and I tried and now
ladies and gentlemen fasten your seat
belts you know man your battle station
the iron and of course the great Ollie
was famous for saying you know I'm so
pretty
I'm ready to rumble rumble young man
Rumble moodini Brown would join in and
they go would float like a butterfly
sting like a bee rumble young man Rumble
yeah so I started to say let's get ready
to rumble there's nothing like you here
today you know I would just say you know
let's get ready to rumble ten rounds of
boxing in the middleweight division I
didn't you know I didn't want it to be
like hey I'm trying to make something
out of myself but I wanted something to
get the crowd energized and a few years
later when I started doing shows all
over the country I met a guy out here in
LA named Jody buries it's passed away
and he was a singer he used to used to
be the opening act for Ella Fitzgerald
and supper clubs were real big in the
50s and 60s this guy was like he was mr.
show business
he had the always had the cufflinks and
wear an ascot and had the Clark Gable
mustache pompadour you know great guy
and we were out drinking one night and
he's had a few and he says buffer when
you say let's get ready to rumble shut
the [ __ ] up
Jody I said people want to react this is
coming from a guy that performed one
stage live and everything the best
advice I ever got it was the best advice
I ever got it was it just it made a big
difference because then I started
instead of saying let's get ready to
rumble 10 rounds up I started saying
let's get ready to rumble
then it was let's get ready to rumble
you know I did it and it grew and I shut
up and the audience would react and of
course you know when we started doing
Mike's fights in the late 80s and early
90s and you know with Spinks and the
fights in Atlantic City that became it
became pretty popular and it made a big
difference dude is awesome it's one of
my favorite sayings in all sports you
know it's been such a blessing for me
Bachmann big again my dad let me bark
them big again
it gives me that makes my skin [ __ ]
but you know I said been blessed I've
done it four Stanley Cup championships
World Series NFL playoff games home
openers for the seasons for different
sports NBA championships yeah that's so
awesome it's it's a great way to start
off a sporting event and you know for me
it's just very exciting to be there and
enjoy that stuff it's up there with as I
played in the NFL it's up there with the
flyover with the Blue Angels jets flying
over let's get ready to rumble though
it's the same feeling you're just
[ __ ] fired up and ready to rock after
that it's and when you do a big stadium
and a really or a really big fight you
ever do one Luton Wembley yeah
90,000 Nate H a and Klitschko that's
90,000
and that was showbiz the ring walks yeah
you know that the British fans might
like you said like they're the best that
they're knowledgeable they're supportive
listen right even if you beat their guys
they respected it come watch you fight
you get three thousand come on play to
watch you fight the three thousand five
thousand people come watch when fight
remember when ricky hatton fought
Pacquiao twenty thousand Brits came to
Vegas fifteen thousand of them knew they
couldn't go to the fight okay Wow but
they just wanted to have their feet on
the ground where Ricky was you know and
of course they opened up the ballrooms
and had closed-circuit TVs for him
everything
Wow it was unbelievable the way in was
the unreal I mean just all these British
fans mm well you know I was going to
England I could do impaired on hard
times and I will go to England my wife
and my kid we were going there will be
two dinners we sit down and dinners and
people would go have action and this is
just amazing
they love fighting in this sports stars
that much they have dinners for Mike you
can't walk you can walk down the street
London or Manchester no way no way hey
no way
no it's great they know they scare you
it's scary
are you scared you can't control them
you can't stop they know they know where
your hotel is yeah they can there's
nothing like you would ever imagine a
polite but they're there Anya damn your
faith baby and they start crying and
children everybody there this is crazy
man they just want a little peace it's
great a good fans out I mean they're
loyal they give you the mementos from
their family's history it's just crazy
is Anthony Joshua British yes yes
London great people incredible people
yeah olds race of people they've been
here forever
yeah it's amazing they forced Julius
Caesar there are there are Roman ruins
in the UK where the Romans were
everywhere you know so yeah that's
insane
like I gotta tell you something I'm
gonna make it come back into the NFL I
know I know it's crazy I don't know I
don't know if I'm in NFL football shape
but you know everything we talk about
man it's just like you know living your
truth in the the will of the universe
and I just feel like I'm being pulled
back in the football man I don't think
we can do this podcasting cool with that
Mike Mike you're wearing the rake on
wireless earphones they're so stylish
and discreet I didn't even notice them
it is great khans of so small I don't
even know that any that but I hear them
really well
aren't they half the price of premium
earbuds yeah go to buy rake on Comm
slash Tyson to get 15% off rake on
wireless earbuds if you've been eyeing a
pair now is the time to get an amazing
deal go to buy rake on Comm forward
slash Tyson for 15% of them what do you
think of the state of boxing these days
because of not just social media but
communications today compared to 25
years ago it's bigger than ever and yeah
you know a lot of people are always
saying well MMA is is taking over from
boxing MMA has a solid loyal fan base
okay but they could never MMA you you
can't have 50 fights every weekend and
at a championship level or you know like
I mean you go on the internet and you go
to like the different boxing sites and
what's happening this weekend you'll see
a half dozen to a dozen really good
cards worldwide and because of
communications and the satellites and
especially social media now and YouTube
a fight fan doesn't have to miss any
fight at any time maybe they watch it on
a repo
or whatever but they're going to see it
so I think boxing is bigger than ever
and you know I work in the UK all the
time unbelievably supportive the fights
at your call where the holds I don't
even know nine hundred twelve hundred
people packed the o2 arena just have it
the English love and they'll be there
and they'll be there for eight fights
all the Olly fights you know you watched
you watch down to the babies is in the
baby's blood hmm
no no serious what do you if you see you
seen the look and look in for coming
daddy I want to fight that boy over
there those trip out of the blue yes
that's only are the Warriors they're
over the ancestors were worried they
foot to your season so interesting yeah
it's amazing great fans it comes to
football which we call soccer forget
about it yeah you know yeah you forget
about it
nice and proper and respectable and
Inlet there's blood does they want to
fight it's so interesting you know what
I love is when it it's a tradition where
they play Sweet Caroline before the main
event oh yeah yeah really
oboe the whole audience gets into it so
over the last couple years when they
play it I get in the ring and I like egg
the crowd oh and I'm going like this
those you know like Hulk Hogan like you
know make that side and I run over the
other side and then they try to outdo
each other it's it's they're great fans
it's so awesome are you related to Bruce
Buffer you made my brother his brother
yeah Wow yeah how do you cuz I mean he's
he's really did you guys grow I mean
when he when you took over this yeah
it's a very interesting story I have two
brothers Bruce and Brian buffer Brian
has retired the cop here in LA well and
I was born I'll be 75 in 10 weeks you
look unbelievable unbelievable we have a
snapper
I was born in born in 44 during World
War two I'm a dude ish damn man my
parents were married like at 18 19 years
old World War two she's pregnant he goes
off and of the War II comes back they I
mean they don't even know each other but
well you know at the age of 11 months
because you know she had to go and work
and and so I went to live with foster
parents in the Philadelphia area who I
ended up staying there my whole life so
whenever I say mom and dad I'm talking
about the people that raised me well
just like when you say mom sometimes
you're referring to
you know Camellia and it's it's that
relationship you know that's what
matters and I always knew my real mother
growing up I saw her you know every
Sunday afternoon we went to the movies
in everything and so it was perfectly
normal for me to have you know have this
home and then Christmas can you have
another parent come in and bring
presents so it's great you know I had to
leave it to beaver life in the 50s the
same exact thing yeah Brooklyn yeah so
when I I was raised with the last name
Huber hu BER that was my foster parents
name social security number high school
diploma says michael huber 1965 I enlist
in the army and my birth certificate has
buffer on it and so the very first day I
go to report for service and get sworn
in they Oh kid by the way your name
isn't Huber anymore its buffer so I
became Michael buffer at age 20 and yeah
and then 25 29 years later I get a phone
call where I'm doing the fights at Dan
goossens receipt a country club on ESPN
a phone call comes in it says a guy by
the name of Joe buffer called and said
give him a call now I always knew my my
birth father's real name and here he
lived in LA lived out in Malibu and
everything and that's how we met Wow
that's how I met Bruce and Brian great
guys
Joe buffers wife little mama the mother
of Bruce
Brian it's like now I've got a third
mother and she's still with us thank god
she's in her in her 80s and as beautiful
as ever and so it just turned out to be
great Bruce Brian was a cop Bruce was
like this businessman and you know so I
you know that and then those days late
80s I'm starting to get a lot of phone
calls like do you want to do this come
to the Cowboys open the game that you
know and so it's really hard you can't
negotiate for yourself you know Mike
you've got agents you got representation
so I said the Bruce I said look why
don't you take these phone calls and you
know and we'll make the deals you know
and and we'll and Plus work that a thing
we formed a partnership
I had the trademark you know was cooking
and I said you know you go out and knock
on doors and and you know we'll we'll
push the trademark and appearances and
it worked out then I got a job with this
thing called UFC and it was like they
had their fourth or fifth show and I did
three of them and those days they
couldn't get licensed anywhere so I had
to go to Montana whatever but at the
same time I had a great deal with WCW
wrestling with the Eric Bischoff on TNT
and it was when arrested Lee the
wrestling wars were on man
WWF ratings were ten each attend share
on cable do you know the Kardashians
don't get tens Wow
it was like unbelievable so they were
raiding each other and so WCW had Hulk
Hogan ready macho we beasts tomorrow I
was with WWE we beat them all we broke
the records yeah yeah we beat everybody
we broke all the records we beat
everybody during the battle between the
two raw and what was the call to WCW
nitro Monday night yeah yeah motive
everyone at the same time and they each
got tens twenty percent of all cable was
watching professional wrestling yes
so anyway Joe W so Turner and WCW they
said look you know we got that you got
this fat contract we would appreciate it
if you didn't do that that that UFC
stuff that's going nowhere
so eventually like you know Bruce
occasionally would do like an undercard
for me and he was and he was really you
had those pipes and everything and Bruce
has actually trained in MMA he's really
knowledgeable and also you know he said
would you mind if I he like try to get
my foot in the door said man you know
I'll go for you hind it you go for you
know and that's how he got into the UFC
and over 20 years now in it he's just
he's a superstar oh definitely
family I talk to them yeah hey told me
said he said tell Mike I said hi that's
so awesome man
what an incredible story that is yeah
juh knock so he was kind of your de
facto agent for a little while still is
still oh yeah oh yeah now we still we
still have that wasn't it awesome when
you met them cuz it's my family it
really is yeah it's you know a lot of
things that happened to me that are just
amazing like if some people they think
like oh man you were in foster care
no that was the best thing ever happened
to me I was blessed with with a family I
had I had a sister and I had a mom and
dad we took vacations and I grew up in
the suburbs of Philadelphia and it was
amazing best thing ever happened to me
oh you went into the Army during the
Vietnam War three years I never got sent
west of Fort Knox Kentucky I mean it's
it's the luck of the draw man yeah I'm
making a living with my voice 11 years
ago I have throat cancer mmm tumors so I
had right now it my whole left side of
my my lymph nodes and everything taken
out tonsils little teeny piece the back
of my tongue 3 2 & 3 little tumors 30
days later I was back in the ring after
I thought was 63 and I thought I was
done you know I figured after surgery I
won't have a voice anymore and it's it's
it's luck man it's it's a bless it's not
just my car brother my sister in the car
you know that we think I'm not smart
enough to have all this stuff yeah and
arrange myself back in this position so
I know I'm not steering the car me is
very grateful to God and the energy to
be yeah that's awesome you're still
doing fights right uh you know for the
first time I'm exclusive mmm for 36
years a lot of people always thought I
was I I was working for HBO mm-hmm but
when I first started you know and and
and Mike actually you know made HBO
explode then you made Showtime explosion
I used to do I used to do I used to do
all the fights top-ranked with mostly
top-ranked fights but on HBO and
Showtime and we've you know weekend
fights and then take other jobs too I
was worked for the promoters as an
independent so then this guy and Don
King leave HBO and go to show times and
he's going to fight razor ruddock in
1991 and you remember Jerry Solomon with
Budweiser mm enjoy okay so I'm all set
to do the fight you know Jay Larkin was
with ya ten days before the fight in
Vegas I get a call from Jerry Solomon
and he says I got some bad news for you
I don't know what you want to do he said
but Seth Abraham the header with HBO the
head of sports and entertainment HBO
Sports says you if you do the fight on
Showtime hmm you can never work on HBO
true story I'm told
what are you talking about it's like two
weeks away says now you know so I have
to call up the Dinkins and Jay Larkin
and and let me say look you know I've
been told and at that time away yeah
Holyfield had the title yes right he had
gotten it from Buster holy pod title
he's gonna fight George Foreman HBO is
gonna have this TV KO which bombed out
and
so I have to make this choice and I'm
independent but I have to make a choice
if that happened like ten years later I
would sue the hell out of him and walk
away with a you know a seven-figure a
settlement a heartbeat but you know back
then like 1991 yeah anyway and they were
and Jay was saying like is it money do
you want more money I you know I'm gonna
have to make a choice and I so I went
with the HBO fights and Foreman and
Holyfield was the next fight there and
then it was great because Jimmy God has
got his chance and put him in a Hall of
Fame so things you know it's a blessing
sometimes it's it you don't think it's
good worked out great for me and it
worked out great for someone else too
you know I was the first one to say it's
Showtime yeah how do you feel when those
big intimidating corporations are back
they were bullies and star fight was
either fight tooth and nail with right
there I knew them when they first got in
the office so I wasn't you know and they
were feeling smelling him so they're
like big top they became like tough guys
all of a sudden yeah it's true
corporate America man that's what they
try to do was [ __ ] control everything
and after I made that choice I would go
to a set and I say like well you know
how about uh you know we make a deal and
I even I even made an offer back then
where I said listen how big are we able
to make those assets you you can you can
use I'll make a deal with you if you
hire me as part of the broadcasting use
let's get ready to rumble for promotion
put it on HBO shirts and ass Annette and
I just guarantee that I do every fight
as I know yeah but you know what it all
worked out pretty good because come
moving forward I had planned on retiring
at the end of last year I was gonna
retire at the end of 2018
yeah 74 I mean what they know things are
looking good how many mortgage I got
cars with no payments
like yeah I love life oh yeah and along
comes Eddie Hearn and it's that berry
and does own and they gave me a couple
million good reasons to be exclusive for
them from so that's where I am right now
where I do fights just for matram boxing
and on the zone and Mister zone thing
man you need a home that's all our
objective in boxing I want a home I'm
gonna home with this television company
I went on with this cable company on
whatever this is my home this is
confident revenue even when we're not
fighting yeah by them and I made this
deal with them and three months later
HBO went out of business in the Box it's
gone yeah Wow
hey man you got to just keep evolving
itseif growing you've taken what the
universe brings you how much longer you
want to keep doing it just until until
you can't come on god I don't know I I
have another year to go in the contract
and we'll see you after that we'll see
maybe I'll just just special appearances
right yeah I mean that the voice but
thank you very much Mike I appreciate
that
what do you think of Mike in this stage
of his life what do you think people a
lot of people actually ask me that like
you know what else Mike Tyson what's
what's what's he really like this and
that and the most important thing is
Mike is happy in his own skin yeah you
know Mike Tyson is glad to be Mike Tyson
no doubt about that yeah you know and
there are there are there there were
times in your life where I don't think
you were well yeah you know and and
there's nothing better than being an
adult being a grown-up not a kid anymore
feeling good feeling healthy married to
the perfect woman you got kids you got a
life an income
you're in a position to help other
people and Mike Tyson is happy in his
own skin and I feel like it's awesome no
doubt it's been such a pleasure I've got
I've known Mike for a little over a year
now and it's been just the most awesome
experience and then 35 years man puberty
so yeah let me get married go through my
marrow that's amazing a funny story
we're in Tokyo Cubs fight right and he
had just gotten married to Robin and her
mother was you know I mean I'm quite a
few years older than Mike and everything
and Mike says hey yeah would you like to
go out with my mother-in-law look at
woman may give a comment above him
you're testing the waters and I believe
she liked them I think yes I will go
yeah you're just saying if Mike was
interested it's nice like did Ali come
to that fight yes yeah and he was still
you know you know we both know Vic then
he started giving yeah it was just just
just at the edge but he was still doing
the magic tricks the the location
invitation that they'd have this fake
thumb it stick in his hand they would
take a hanky and go like this and then
the fake thumb and he go you know and
you didn't know it's like you know I
need get that hand away real quick they
had this dopey-looking film understand
but that was Ollie and and no matter
what who you were with he could be with
your mom you'd be with your wife or
girlfriend and he would always Oh
girlfriend and then he would put his arm
around her make believe he's gonna walk
away he always did that right either
that with everybody was
but he said to my wishes my I wish I was
back in young again yeah I would have
you but as the years went by you know
you had when you talked to Holly you had
to actually put your ear right up right
up to his mouth you know and and cuz it
was like this and and he waved me over
and I put my ear there and he'd say I'm
still prettier than you he would he did
that forever
god bless him Oh what I just you know I
can remember like it was yesterday
watching a black-and-white TV in 1960
and Cassius Marcellus clay this 173
pound flawless athlete fighting in the
Olympics in Rome you remember them I
remember him and I was what 15 years old
oh just just amazing and you know he I
remember fighting Spinks I mean when
that was understood I was picked parking
for my dad and [ __ ] fight was on in
the store and the person was looking at
the fighting that's how I was able to
get get his money out of his pocket and
I remember watching him fight Holmes
broke my heart
yeah and you know and he was he had
medication that he was supposed to take
her like a thyroid medication he was and
so he tripled the medication because it
was he would it would make him lose
weight rapidly and he looked remember
how good he looked but his skin was ashy
it was a just something wasn't there
they he look slim and he was older then
and it just wasn't there you know I mean
like as much as we loved Ollie he did
not like to stay in shape between fights
no you know Roberto's the same way would
you say that's why I got that bad habit
from watching Ali and Roberto durán no
this is the story I knew idols yes
listen this is something that this is a
bad habit
these guys would um maybe they wouldn't
fight they bi press conference every
fattest pigs at press conference get
ready for the guy in six weeks a week
three I'm six weeks or something maybe a
month or something and they're so
arrogant look at laughing people are
talking doing that stuff and the next
thing you know they're getting a gym and
they just dying and it'll eat no food
they don't drink no water will just
[ __ ] sweat suit all day until they go
to bed in the morning take the hot tub I
thought some bath put the suit back on
run all day with a suit or they hit
chopping trees riding a bike Shadow Ball
killing himself
yeah all day they're working out all
[ __ ] day for a month yeah a week all
day died and hot bad steam room exercise
shadowbox the exercise the punch
disbarment jumping rope all day little
water or animals well all day just to
get back this what happens they weigh in
the perfect way soon as they finish when
they start go again
yeah but they do that today these guys I
mean guys that a fight as a middleweight
today are light heavyweights yeah if
they had to weigh in the morning of the
fight they'd be fighting as a light
heavyweight Canelo comes in he gains 18
pounds hmm remember when James Toney
fought Roy yes
he gained 18 pounds in less than 24
hours and he couldn't lift his feet off
the growth than that you know must know
how to do it muscle tissue takes 48
hours to rehydrate hmm so they're
they're a day short of their peak you
know they're not as good as it could be
yeah but you talked about Roberto but
they're doing this man went after the
after the way they suck even in the bed
- eating in a bit sucking on eating grub
and food eating fruit grapes just me
chewing steak and spitting it out all of
me the tuna gods being on that chewing
them
yeah they can't all day dehydrate
whoo-whoo just imagine Roberto durán
though he won over a hundred fights
and after he moved up from lightweight
to welterweight he never trained between
fights when he went to that two and
three fights a year thing listen he be
195 we got to go to 135 baby me 180 I go
to 135 baby a little 147 baby
we look like snowmen when he got when
they got knocked out by Tommy yeah which
was brutal and he had never been to
taken out like that he came down in like
eight nine weeks from 195 to 154 I mean
come on that's you're killing yourself
Hey he just was lethargic in the ring
but the guy would you look at him today
his skin is nice I mean just imagine if
he stayed in shape between fights yeah
he'd look like a movie star
I mean he just was he really was a great
defensive fighter something she's a dad
a lot affecting your nervous system yeah
that fluctuation and weight definitely
it's not no yeah down like that we're
the only species that could do no no
we're the only species that kill us
suffering and the urge of improving
ourselves with the idea that we're
improving ourselves let me say that
except with the notion that we're
improving ourselves with the only
species that kills ourself in that
process weight pills and all this all
these pits that burn is all this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that you stick what's that [ __ ]
calling in the needles growth hormone
steroids PG can't stop we're addicted to
it you can't stop it yeah it's true
man Michael I mean it's been awesome
having you in here brain that's been
great to be here a lot of fun it's
really a pleasure
that's your vet out there yeah we gotta
go check boxes ah laughing that's a
limited-production zr1 755 horsepower
that's number four for four out of I
think eighteen hundred made and now they
come out and I got it it's it's a 2019
and I got it like six months before
anybody else yeah because I do a few
NASCAR races it had some Chevy
connections I got it I've been driving
these Mercedes and everything said man I
go back to getting a Corvette zero to
sixty and two point eight five that's
car in the world oh that car Escalade oh
I got my third Escalade and now you know
what my wife sees one of these g60
threes look at you we got five dogs that
she's not yeah the dogs will love that
the dogs I love that my Cadillac for
that yeah you can pay me to take my
Cadillac the Caddy dude it's in
comfortable I love that Escalade yes I
got my third one man three in a row
where can people find you where can
people check you out they can go to
let's Rumble dot-com let's Rumble Darko
and that'll go to the office and/or info
at let's Rumble calm and get in touch
with us and everybody half the party
that the fight that was good times baby
that oh my god you know Mike you know
what's funny is Atlantic City all right
we'll run into guys from 25 and 30 years
ago and like I never saw this guy up who
says hey you remember that night the
Atlantic City we want the buddies bar
and you know we got drunk and I'm like
who the [ __ ] is this guy yeah it's some
guy was on the other side of the bar and
he's like sent a couple drinks over and
like for the rest of his life he partied
with me you know he said yeah party with
Michael buffer I have no
idea I've ever running these guys all
the time I'm like oh yeah good to see
you again and my wife will say like yeah
no you have no idea who that is
guys like that don't exist no more you
still find guys like that I can't find a
guy like that a couple years ago I'm in
a nice restaurant in New York and a guy
comes over to the table and he says he
you're a guy your dad ready to rumble
guy he's like say it for me I'm like hey
listen I said if you were a plumber
would I like ask you to fix my toilet
for free I mean come on I'm here having
dinner it'll be a time like in the AIDS
when he was said that you said lets get
ready to rhumble could he know it
because circumstances after that Nicky
Scarfo knows guys who there was
psychopath yeah they were band they were
banned from dick they weren't allowed on
property Atlantic City Wow it was and
man I would run into those guys in clubs
and that sort of thing and they all
wanted to like hey give me your phone
number right I will keep in touch yeah I
can like you know these guys their
phones are all bugged yeah that's what I
need is to have them call me I was they
are you doing you want to come over
South Philly tonight and have a couple
of cheesesteaks yeah they didn't fool
around they killed the whole South
Jersey they wiped everybody out they
weren't playing around everything they
had the union's everything Atlantic City
you'd get you get it found you get a
towel in Atlantic City and you dry your
face and you had lint all over your face
yeah and that's because you had to use
the mobs shitty linen rental company it
was just like junk uh oh it's crazy
everything video stood anyone open the
video store anything anyone open up you
have to go to the mob they own all the
real estate was Jimmy Hoffa in that was
he in that part of the country
shakaal North Chicago for my time that
we should Carlo
I think he's supposed to be right by on
a resting-place supposed to be the
Meadowlands right they say that
underneath underneath the the field is
that's crazy I was looking on YouTube
day you're not many missing celebrities
they really is disappeared no what the
hell here's a YouTube video about
celebrities dissipated thin air I gotta
check that out basketball plays and I
wanna see if I'm on the list
yeah thanks hopefully never
oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] man thank you so much
thanks for sharing a knowledge is fun
sharing your voice I mean I think we're
gonna use that intro from now on so Mike
you're gonna come to Riyadh Saudi Arabia
I wanted to do that to see the five-year
high I'm gonna send I want to send an
email to somebody today and see if they
can like you know get in touch with you
okay beep it's a heavy way yeah in case
somebody's watching right now we're
talking about December 7 is AJ and Andy
Ruiz rematch there we go Saudi Arabia
there we go my brother's over there
yeah like you should definitely be
laughter though they be sick it's
awesome you're you're bringing the fight
in come I will be there yeah it's a
match room is the promoter and it's
going to be on the zone here in the
states I kind of have a schedule wise in
the West Coast they'll probably have to
watch it around noon whoa and 9 or 10
o'clock in the UK so that's like 3
o'clock in the afternoon in New York but
fight fans will find a way yes they will
stay well Mike you got anything else
ain't appreciate John you create such a
presence this was awesome experience for
the fans
good to be here Mike absolutely it was
good to see you Friday night to it all
charity event wasn't that hey what's up
with the pump brother
there creates a it is amazing man they
know everybody everybody in basketball
baseball I'm talking the guys in my in
my hotel room we're talking I think they
put on the phone is Jamie Foxx who you
want Mike who are the pub brothers a
couple of guys from the valley yeah
Alden Northridge okay their mom and dad
both passed away from cancer and they
for 19 years in their parents name they
have raised millions and millions of
dollars and for cancer research and and
oncology and chemotherapy and radiation
and yes screening and may my family be
friends with them for under 2 years and
stuff and we just wouldn't help them
whenever they need us yeah good guys in
some they put together a thing every
August first week of August and man hey
the who's who was sports yes whoever you
are dr. J was there my celebrities Jack
just yes just for Mike yeah just for
Mike with Shaq Evander buster yeah Jim
Gray yes is amazing I've just for like
Mike's and then because award right
Antonina Cedric and Eddie Murphy was
there for said it's super Eddie looks
great my god he does look good
subjects they can they have like five
awards and they categorize each one but
it's like it they honor each guy one was
it a doctor that's done great research
oh you and Danny oh my god this guy
actually found a way to have dogs smooth
smelled the breath and tell if somebody
has diabetes cancer skin yeah I'm scared
a man devoted his whole
[Laughter]
all 911 what no [ __ ]
wow that's amazing I know that's so
awesome
that I mean it's amazing what they're
doing now you know
oh the advancements of science on that
note we're gonna we're gonna get out of
here let's do it man
well thanks for watching and listening
watching and listening everybody be sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel hot
box and with Mike Tyson check out our
website hot box and podcast calm until
next time i'm evan britain and i'm mike
tyson and let's get ready for hot box in
Oh in the house we're out of here
MB
[Music]